and the Minneapolis Star Tribune reports
on the release of dashcam video showing
the moment a police officer shot falando
Casteel officer Geronimo llanes pulled
Castille over last July before firing
into his car he was found not guilty of
manslaughter last week and the shooting
gained nationwide attention after the
victims girlfriend livestream the
aftermath on Facebook Mireya Villarreal
is here with more on this story Maria
good morning
well good morning the disturbing dashcam
video was shown to the court jurors but
was not made public until Tuesday while
it does show the shooting it does not
show what happened inside the car or
what Officer Yanis saw the dashcam video
shows officer Geronimo Llanes asking
falando Casteel for his license and
registration
moments after stopping him for a broken
taillight Castillo calmly explains he is
armed
the 29 year old officer fired seven
shots within 90 seconds of making the
stop the officer just shot him in his
arm
cuz Steele's girlfriend Diamond Reynolds
was in the passenger seat and
live-streamed what followed on Facebook
he have you thought him get his ID sir
his driver's license oh my god please
don't tell me he's dead
Reynolds then four-year-old daughter who
was in the backseat can be seen
hesitating before a second officer
carries her away
Yanis is later heard recounting what
happened to a fellow officer
Yanis claimed he feared for his life he
was charged with second degree
manslaughter in November her own grave
represented units the only choice an
officer Yanis had based on his training
was to defend himself in the safest
manner possible and that's what he did
on Friday the jury acquitted yet is of
all charges
prompting thousands across the Twin
Cities to protest including Castillo's
mother Valerie he shat into a car with
no regard for human life
and that's okay thank you menace
sullivan Casteel had a permit to carry a
firearm at the time of the shooting an
attorney for the Casteel family says
they are planning to file a civil
lawsuit
Yanis was dismissed from the st. Anthony
Police Department following Friday's
verdict Jeff Wright thank you